everybody look at him once man he's not
going to stand up again all right so I
want you to write me my co-host and then
our [__] producer go from one to ten
just off Beauty go
if you don't know what this is I don't
know what this is but it's something it
looks familiar yeah this is the discount
fresh and Fit I would rate you first
already me and then him and then him go
um I'll rate you a seven all right what
is he I'll rate you an eight or an owl
rate Josh and eight also okay what about
you go uh I would rate you a
eight okay
nine okay
come on he just [__] stood up bro
like come on I would say nine all right
what about you over there go
two okay
I was given a nine okay what is what is
she over there I give him a ten because
he advises me all right so again
you sound like a stupid ass [__]
nothing changes you sound like oh no she
called him a two
change
and
he that's the thing if I go after some
if the person oh my Dave it's like this
guy is a girl that goes up to you and
says does this [__] make me look fat and
you're like yeah kinda and it's like ah
bear you that's you you asked I'm not
gonna lie if a girl said I was a two out
of 10 I would just laugh
one because I think the ratings absurd
but also because I don't really care
that deeply Oh my days he's the thing if
you've been with women if you've dated
then you know you should have an idea of
where you're at you you act like I don't
need to ask I know where I'm at because
of my experience you asked you asked to
give you a little diaper keep a push
and the reason why I think this
interaction is funny is a lot of these
guys who run these men's podcasts who
want to tell men how to live their lives
or like some of the most sensitive most
ungentlemanly most like whatever
uncivilized people you could imagine
it's like why would I want to take cues
from a loser like you bro you getting
pressed on a podcast because your girl
says she don't think you cute keep it
pushing my dude like if you getting
women like let's just use that if you
get you don't even care
I have never cared when a woman said I
didn't lose it why because I've had it
doesn't matter hey maybe the only people
who care are people who like have some
kind of deep seated issue and it comes
out every time a girl says no
because if you actually getting it a
girl says no you keep it moving the only
dudes who can like go up to a girl she
has no boy [__] you did this kiss you
got issues my guy
but hey if I'm lying guys you guys in
the comments below if you've done this
okay let me ask you a girl saying no did
it bother you okay he said he said
you're a stupid ass let me let me hear
why let me hear what okay why are you
rated me a two because you're not we're
not going off our interactions we're
going off Beauty I don't like light skin
[__] I don't give a [__] he's
light-skinned just like me and you just
gave him a nine you gave me a two you
only gave me a two because of the whole
interaction that we've been having right
so do me a favor get the [__] up and get
the [__] out thank you yeah get out it's
lame it's corny is is is is reheated
it's it's yeah
yo it's not even entertaining like I was
there's nothing to say about this ever
since fresh outfit made this format
popular I've seen a lot of podcasts kind
of spring up with the same ideas like
two two male hosts and then a bunch of
like women and Bobby hey I'm Gonna Keep
it inside I couldn't imagine getting up
every day and send a bunch of women who
I find undesirable or annoying and then
having to lecture them every single day
about life like I would just get so
[__] bored but everyone has a
different interest we do reaction
content so some people don't find that
interesting everything goes everybody
that they think but I don't know it's
just funny to me that's all this is like
even this whole interaction doesn't get
me mad or upset it's just whatever go to
therapy I think I think you might I
think there should be some therapy bro
and it's not even as an insult no it's
not even it's not even as an insult like
go to it's not that
for real for real my guy yeah like it's
it's it's not a dis it's not something
like to come at you
you're hurt something happened I don't
know what it is you need therapy that's
therapy [__] I think everybody needs
therapy but you no no no not everyone
needs therapy that's not true I don't
think everyone needs therapy I would say
this when I say therapy or I'm just
saying is like you need some
self-reflection and some growth that's
it that's all it is because like that's
what even have this phenomenon in the
red pill they call it red pill rage it's
like when you discover the truth or
whatever you get angry and I could say
that there's been a period in my life
where there's been a negative resentment
towards women due to the Past
Experiences I've gone through it's like
I'm fine with that I understand it like
I get it what I just understand is when
you're going through that face and
you're trying to lecture man about how
to live life like bro you haven't even
gone through half of your Evolution and
you're out here telling dudes how they
got to get it it's like relax
relax
you can't even put on a good face in
front of the cameras imagine what you
like off camera and a lot of guys are
lost or don't know what to do when it
comes to women or how so they look to
these guys who are surrounded by women
and they're like oh this guy must be
having it oh this is how you gotta talk
to the ladies right I bet you these guys
probably got fresh and fit favorite And
subscribe to and uh they hit the
notification Bell that's where they're
getting the accused from it's like a lot
of dudes gotta hear whatever they got
going on where they're so angry
resentful don't get me wrong I'm not
saying women are perfect or whatever
it's not that my whole point is if
you're doing half decent life you're not
getting this mad
that's all and I say this because I've
I've been around dudes who I consider
great leaders I've been around men who I
thought were Community oriented and
people to be emulated and respected and
none of them ever talk like this or
acted like this certainly not in public
never ever ever not that I've seen and
if I did find out I would look at them
completely different because I'm like
bro how you put on
all this and try to lead men but then
you talking to people like this because
she rated you with two who cares she
didn't volunteer that information you
asked her then she gave you an answer
you didn't like that you said [__] get
the [__] up out of here
I don't know to me that just us
what I checked out you checked out ah
it's so [__] lame
yo and maybe they're gonna do to go up
to women what's up Mom what's up Mom
yeah and then [__] you then that's you
that's it that's so [__] lame yeah
like a level one [__] door come on
[__] you even evolve yet and you
trying to uh well this is how you do
this [__] you don't you don't know how
to do [__] you don't know about how to
go about life yourself you get irate
because someone rated you a two God damn
keep it pushing that's what I'm saying
yeah damn that's the best advice I could
give you is when it comes to rejection
stop taking that [__] personal and if
you do then you need to just get used to
talking to people not everyone will like
you this [__] walked up to a
girl and said yo you want to [__] and
she said no [__] you then you a stupid
ass [__] you asked you're the one to
ask that's what I'm saying what
you asked
ain't nobody was about everybody was
about their business they didn't do
nothing you go and you ask for some they
tell their opinion because mind you it's
an opinion and then you're like yo we
like skin I'm not kidding like him how
are you going to give him
shut up
he he didn't even hear yourself when you
[__] talk did you hear that did you
said that how makes you huh he likes kid
like me are you gonna do
change your diaper dude what the [__] is
wrong with you Hey listen God damn he
likes California
I'll say this guys if you're watching
Embrace rejection it's fine yeah it
sucks a little bit the feeling
but the way you should be approaching it
and this is how I was taught anyways
it's a girl said no on to the next one
who's
I remember we used to go to the club
okay and they used to tell us the moment
you go in a person first person you see
good or hot ugly did matter why just get
the first one out the way after you get
the first one out of the way just start
talking to the next person even when she
says no it doesn't matter keep pushing
but the last thing you
have to get up in the club a girl says
no Then you make a scene guess what
every other business doesn't seem that
[__] everybody doesn't see you yelling
with a woman and don't even matter if
she deserved it or anything all they see
is a grown man yelling at a woman in a
club and all of a sudden your social
value is plummeted to [__] zero
this is the most anti-player
anti-macking Behavior you could ever
mention this is anti-charge it's
everything
that's what this is
you know what's your best answer
whenever you get rejected
the best answer you can get
okay that's the best thing when someone
rejects you yeah oh okay and then you
leave I'll say this this is not even
just true for dating okay it's not even
just true for date this is true for life
in general when I go to a job and they
say no I try to leave on the best terms
possible I know why because there's a
possibility the job might open in the
future there's a possibility that that
person knows somebody else am I put in a
good word for me that my resume might
circulate when you or a different
position comes up or I'm overqualified
whatever it might be you never want to
just [__] off these doors there's no
reason to or that per like and that same
thing translates to dating if a girl
says no I just keep it pushed as long as
things didn't go south there's a
possibility that line that things might
happen maybe I'm interested maybe she's
interested or maybe none of us are
interested at that point who knows or
she's got a friend who might you never
know with these things so there's just
no benefit to blowing up the spot just
because somebody said no for your own
Prosperity just do not look at this kind
of behavior think this is good yeah I
told that [__] up who you trying to
impress it's not the right impression
that you're trying to make man maybe it
is maybe you guys just want to seem
Undateable or I don't I don't take no
[__] from nobody
that's not what you look like that's
what you look like that's not what you
look like it'll look like you can't
handle enough
stupid ass [__]
[Music]
make sure she gets her bag on phone too
make sure she doesn't take the wrong
[__] phone dummy that's how you think
the interaction with the rest of the
girls are gonna be like they just see
that [__] they're like all on edge not
comfortable it's like the hate man it's
fun it's funny like you this new age of
so-called players or whatever are the
biggest dorks and like uncool I got hurt
in high school so now I want to tell
everybody how much they deserve pain
losers I don't ever see them in my life
every every player that I've seen that
was successful every guy that I've seen
I was getting girls successfully were
cool calm and collected yep
there was some kind of oof some kind of
oomph some kind of pizzazz some kind of
spice and they think you understand what
I'm saying when they was walking to a
girl it was super smooth super relaxed
they would flip that they would flip or
no one to a yes rather than do it all
Outburst it would just flip it oh yeah
that's a no it's okay they would do a
little something and by the end they
will still manage to get it because they
were was able to flip it around why
because there was no outburst
there was no like insults and stuff like
that true they were not entitled to
whatever it is
no they just went on about their
business did they thinking at the end it
was still getting it to be fair there
were corny [__] even back in the day
that's not what I'm saying but the only
difference is I said they weren't the
ones running everything or telling dudes
how to live their lives nowadays you got
corny [__] everywhere trying to tell
young men everybody what it is everybody
got a platform yeah that's the thing
that's what's happening this is the
Revenge of the nerves to the fourth
degree yeah I'm not saying that the the
people didn't have that I'm saying that
the best ones that I've seen yeah the
ones that was really getting in out
there yeah they were cool
calm collected yeah but you do whatever
they want to do and keep on going that
lame ass Fufu ass [__] yeah Rinky Dink
ass Mickey Mouse
operation you're running I don't know
what the [__] it is but it ain't it man
if you think it is yeah lots of the
sauce but maybe y'all feel different so
let us know what you guys think